das ist schön und das riecht gut
das wird uns gleich sehr gut
[Musik]
oh mein Gott wir müssen uns beeilen denn
der Hefeteig geht schon auf
der läuft gleich über aber egal herzlich
Willkommen zu Sallys Welt heute gibt es
ein schnelles Rezept für euch nämlich
pizzaschnecke die Pizza Schnecken könnt
ihr entweder aus einem Blätterteig oder
aus Hefeteig zubereiten ich habe jetzt
hier meinen Pizzateig schon vorbereitet
der ist auch schon ordentlich
aufgegangen und ihr könnt aber auch ganz
gerne Pizzateig aus dem Kühlfach zum
Beispiel nehmen ich weiß es macht nicht
jeder gerne Pizzateig selbst aber ich
empfehle es immer aber wenn es mal
schnell gehen muss oder ihr einfach
keine Lust habt dann nehmt euch halt
Pizzateig oder Blätterteig ich mache das
ganze so ein bisschen klassisch auf
Mamas Art und Weise denn meine Mama wenn
die Pizza macht macht sie immer einen
Topf da kommt alles an Zutaten rein da
wird keine Pizza belegt sondern
bestrichen das heißt einen Pizzateig
alles kommt drauf und wird mit gebacken
und es schmeckt halt schon extrem gut
jedenfalls zeige ich euch die Zutaten
hier ist mein Hefeteig das Rezept findet
ihr auf meinem Kanal und hier sind die
Zutaten ich verwende jetzt hier für eine
Dose Tomatenstücke sind 400 Gramm 50g
Tomatenmark eine Knoblauch Salz Pfeffer
und Oregano und hier die Füllung könnt
ihr jetzt selbst bestimmen ich nehme
etwas Sucuk das ist Knoblauchwurst als
Käse nehme ich hier den kaskaval also
den kashard Käse eine rote Paprika und
grüne Oliven die sind bereits im steint
perfect soweit sehr gut jetzt kommt
Mamas Technik okay erstmal brauche ich
eine große Schüssel
soll ich die jetzt gleich groß genug
nehmen das alles reinpasst oder wieder
zu klein wählen wie immer ich nehme sie
groß
ach ich nehme ich hole eine
die Düfte reichen
und da kommen jetzt erstmal die Tomaten
das Tomatenmark und die Gewürze rein
[Musik]
hat man das gesehen
ja das riecht schon mal wie Mamas
pizzasoße sehr gut
und dann nehme ich die restlichen
Zutaten und ich habe jetzt das jetzt so
zusammengestellt aber ihr könnt zum
Beispiel auch Meister zugeben oder
kleine Peperoni ihr könnt auch alles was
ihr so auf der Pizza mögt also ich mag
jetzt hier die Zutaten aber
Thunfischpizza geht auch Zwiebel Pizza
deine Lieblingspizza
Schinken tatsächlich schinkenpizza ja
das war's mal halt gerne hat kann hier
mit rein vielleicht noch eine kleine
Info falls ihr auch mit Sucuk was
zubereitet das hätten Sucuk das Original
aus Kayseri das hatten wir noch
eingefroren da außen ist immer so eine
Haut die schält man weg ich weiß nämlich
dass viele die nicht weggeschält haben
und einfach mit gegessen haben
die muss man vorher schälen
und dann wird einfach alles fein
gewürfelt
[Musik]
die Paprika schneide ich in feine Würfel
und die Oliven in feine Scheiben
[Musik]
ich nehme jetzt hier als Käse einfach
den cachat Käse den kaskaval von Gazi
das ist wie so eine Art Gouda hat aber
richtig geniale Schmelzeigenschaften
also den nehme ich auch am liebsten für
Toast zum Beispiel mit dem überbacke ich
alles das so der Käse der einfach super
mega gut schmilzt aber wie gesagt auch
roh auf Brot zum Beispiel ganz gut
schmeckt oder eben im Toast und den
nehme ich jetzt und den können jetzt
entweder drüber reiben oder auch in
Würfel schneiden aber ich glaube den
reibe ich gleich einfach komplett oben
drauf
so dann habe ich jetzt hier die Zutaten
und kann hier erstmal alles schön
verrühren
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich hier in der Ofenform habe
meinen Teig den rollig kurz aus
so schön
ich liebe Pizzateig
ja ich liebe Pizzateig einfach ein
schöner Teig und ihr könnt ja noch immer
vorbereiten einfach die Hefemenge
reduzieren dann im Kühlschrank aufgehen
lassen über Nacht
und dann ist er perfekt für den nächsten
Tag da kann man sowas auch mal
vorbereiten
auch für die die sagen Sie jetzt keine
Zeit am Abend noch zu machen
jetzt hier zu einem großen schönen
Rechteck ausräumen
zieht ihn einfach immer so ein bisschen
in Form
Murat halt immer macht den haben wir
auch in Form gezogen letzte 15 Jahre
hier bisschen da bist
so okay wenn er noch seine Ecken und
Kanten hat der Teig
beim Murat Dash einfach perfekt der hat
keine Ecken und Kanten
und da kommt jetzt die komplette Füllung
drauf oh halt die brauchen noch einen
wie heißt denn das Werkzeug
eine Winkelpalette
[Musik]
jetzt kommt hier der Käse drauf der wird
schön drüber gerieben
jetzt wäre es noch eine Blech Pizza
jetzt wäre es noch eine Blech Pizza aber
gleich wird es eine Pizza Schnecke
aber jetzt können wir noch entscheiden
[Musik]
das ist schön und das riecht gut
es wird uns gleich sehr gut schmecken
wieder die Pizza schmecken
okay
jetzt das ganze aufrollen und deswegen
habe ich hier auch dieses Silikonmatte
damit geht es einfacher ist es trotzdem
nicht ganz einfach aber einfacher
doch es ist einfach
[Musik]
ich habe hier eine Ecke gebackform und
da schaue ich dann immer ganz gerne wie
viel ungefähr reinpasst ich denke ich
mache vier Mal drei also 12
Pizzaschnecken das passe ich dann halt
immer so individuell an die Backform an
so wie es dann optisch und von der
Passform her am besten passt jetzt nehme
ich einen Faden denn wenn ihr jetzt mit
dem Messer schneidet dann zerdrückt er
die Schnecke dann ist es keine Schnecke
mehr sondern eher so ein flaches oval
und ich halbiere die jetzt erstmal und
dann noch mal jede Hälfte durch 6 das
Blech dann einfach schön mit Olivenöl
fetten und die Schnecken reinsetzen
[Musik]
darf ich hier das Blech und da setze ich
die Schnecken einfach rein und ein die
eine hängt oh mein Gott
hier jetzt ich hab's ich hab's
jetzt aber schnell bevor die sich so
richtig verformen
[Musik]
fällt mir so gut das sieht wunderbar aus
die Rest Zutaten die jetzt rausgefallen
sind die kommen hier einfach wieder rein
und dann stelle ich die Pizzaschnecken
in den kalten Backofen schaltet dann den
Backofen an und durch die Aufwärmzeit
gehen die Schnecken auch noch mal schön
auf und Backen fertig wow ein richtiges
Massaker hier
ich gehe erstmal hinter waschen und dann
gehen wir noch Backofen und wer will
kann jetzt natürlich noch mal Käse
drüber steuern könnt ihr machen wisst
ihr aber nicht ich glaube am Ende
vielleicht noch mal Käse drüber dass er
jetzt nicht so ganz dunkel wird
[Musik]
so sehen sie jetzt aus die pizzaschnecke
ist ich finde die sind richtig süß
und jetzt darf der
hallo
freue mich schon
wie viel darf ich probieren
seht ihr auf die Hand geben
okay i'm sorry ich beeile mich es riecht
schon so gut ja
was ist alles drin
ja ich errate oder was Käse
hast du großen Hunger ja ich habe immer
Hunger sehr gut deswegen weiß ich auch
immer auch wenn so der Feierabend Naht
weiß ich schon immer der tinder
[Gelächter]
der ist so anständig erzogen Mund das
Sucuk wenn ich der Hammer ja
im Flugzeug mitgebracht obwohl man darf
und die Oliven passen auch gut dazu
also ich kann es nur erahnen weil ich
hatte gerade essen und dann musste ich
auf die Pizza Schnecke warten und dann
haben wir die noch fotografieren müsste
dann durfte ich sie nicht zum
Mittagessen haben und dann bin ich jetzt
satt weil ich hatte noch zwei Cupcakes
oh ich habe meinen Kaffee vergessen
heute Anna du auch und jetzt habe ich
mir so gedacht eigentlich ich hatte den
ganzen Tag Lust auf die pizza-schnecke
neues mitnehmen dann ich probiere eine
später zum Abendessen also wenn Ihr auch
die Pizzaschnecken machen wollt dann
probiert das Rezept gerne aus ihr könnt
es auch wirklich ganz ganz einfach vegan
zubereiten denn der Pizzateig ist vegan
die Tomatensoße genauso Zutaten eurer
Wahl könnt ihr auch dazu geben ob ihr
jetzt einen veganen Käse nehmt oder
einfach keinen Käse und wirklich Gemüse
damit reinpackt schmeckt immer sehr sehr
lecker probiert gern aus das Rezept gibt
auf
ja er will beweisen sallys-block.de
freut euch aufs nächste Video mit dem
Eis sollten wir zwei zusammenpacken
oder magst du lieber zum Essen kommen
Grillen ja machen wir das okay
gut dann packe ich dem Tim jetzt noch
ein paar Schnecke ein und dann sehen wir
uns beim nächsten mal gut
[Musik]